now speaking to you from the control
room of Studio 41 his Edward our morrow
good afternoon in 1938 at the time of
Muni British Prime Minister Neville
Chamberlain said of Czechoslovakia it is
a small nation of which we know nothing
today there are many new small nations
around the world of which we know very
little
they are young in freedom but old in
culture and civilization they like we in
the early days of our nationhood want to
stand aloof from the power struggles of
the day in short they want to be neutral
burma is such a nation it's almost
exactly halfway around the planet from
here in 1949 our foreign aid experts
were inclined to write Burma off a small
nation about nine tens of it already in
the hands of the Communists with only a
very small army and it was led
politically by what was regarded as a
religious fanatic a little man who spent
most of his time meditating Burma today
is still sovereign also still neutral
but like other countries in the area its
major problem is to maintain its freedom
and its neutrality our reporter on this
visit to Burma will be Paul Nevin our
cameraman bill McClure
Bhama Buddhism neutralism what is a
neutral it is an uncommitted nation it
is a land which considers itself in
neither of the two massive power blocks
which divided the world perhaps the most
graphic way of defining Burma's
neutrality is to report two events that
happened on December 12th 1956 9,000
miles apart in Rangoon hi Burmese
officials were greeting premier Joe and
Lai of Communist China
[Music]
this was at the very time when Joel was
defending the Russian butchery in
Hungary
at virtually the same time in New York
City the Burmese ambassador to the
United Nations speaking in the name of
the Burmese government and its people
was addressing the General Assembly
making what is perhaps the most direct
attack any afro-asian neutral has made
on a communist power no nation
large power or small power has the right
though frequently large nations have the
power to COO as other nations its
apologists say that the Soviet Union who
as as Hungary to preserve communism for
Hungary but it has no right to do this
though obviously it has up to the
present the fire so to do my government
feels that it must voice this conscience
must express its condemnation we do this
to keep our self-respect we can do no
less there speaking of Hungary but for
the grace of God movie this is the road
to Mandalay this guarded train preceded
by an armored pilot engine takes two
days to travel the 400 miles from
Rangoon to Mandalay stops at night
because of the insurgents currently less
than 10% of Burma is in the hands of the
rebels in 1950 more than 80% of Burma's
land area was in insurgent hands the
insurgents a collection of communist
Trotskyites currents and bandits total
less than 10,000 in number but at one
time they virtually paralyzed the New
Republic of Burma and even today alas
the government and its people every town
in Burma from MU main to Mandalay to
Michener is sealed to traffic every
night at dusk every Bridge crossing the
Irrawaddy or the salween is guarded
patrols constantly comb the jungle which
the armies of so many nations have cut
their way through in the last 15 years
the Japanese the Chinese the Americans
the British Burma is a country about the
size of Texas ringed by the sea and a
horseshoe of high mountains and no less
than six different nation India and
Pakistan in constant conflict with each
other but both friendly with Burma Tibet
recently absorbed by Red China Laius
recently carved out of Indochina
Thailand which many Asians call an
American satellite and the giant
monolith of communist China the largest
nation on earth and it is this 1500 mile
border with China which keeps Burma both
neutral and vigilant this is the
sprawling city of Rangoon near where the
many mouths of the Irrawaddy empty into
the Bay of Bengal Rangoon is now swollen
to a city of 750,000 because of the
refugees who have streamed in from the
rebel infested interior many of them
could go home now but like other human
tides they tend to stay Rangoon is the
political economic and cultural capital
of the country
this is Rangoon's modern University
9,000 students professors never let
their students forget that Burma was the
third nation in the history of the
British Empire to win its independence
the first to being the American colonies
and the Republic of era professor Jaffa
who once taught history at Yale
University evaluates for his students
the assets and liabilities that Burma
inherited from the British occupation in
the first place
it made possible that is the British
occupation made possible three decades
of intense misery amongst 80% or 85% of
the people when the Delta was being
opened up after the Suez Canal was open
in 1870 the opening up was done by a
small unit small social units of single
Burmese families who were dependent on
the moneylenders for the first two years
of the paeonia work in
the swamps and the mangrove jungles the
dependent for the first two years on the
money that they had to borrow from the
Indian Chettiars and this area's interns
lent money to our burmese cultivators at
anything from 50 to 120 percent per
annum so by 1929 you have officially
simplify percent of the agricultural
land in South Burma in the hands of
aliens and unofficially perhaps much
more than that the professor is also
mindful that Britain helped Burma
prepare for her independence there are
many difficulties that Burma had to face
to rehabilitate itself after the
revenues of the war you know we were
occupied for three years
we are bombed by both science most of
our towns were left let but nevertheless
there had to be a quick rehabilitation a
quick raising of the standards of the
living of the people and the
totalitarian method seemed to promise on
the surface at any rate a shortcut
toward these goals but our leaders were
wiser perhaps they were wiser because
the British taught us some of the values
some of the ideas which they themselves
believed in at which they probably did
not bother to apply to us all the way
anyway but these people our leaders
decided once and for all that we would
choose democracy and that they will
probably have to work harder but that in
the long run in the interests of the
people and of our country over a longer
period democracy was a cup of tea that
they would choose democracy and
therefore you have one more tangible
evidence of it except us are there any
questions that you want to make is there
any possibility of Burma entering into
alliance like Southeast Asia Treaty
Organization well I would like to handle
that but let me do it anyway ah country
is committed for the time being and
perhaps you'll understand why what
time-being to a strict policy of
mutualism I think largely this is to
give us time to allow our country in our
governments in our armed forces to stand
more firmly on their own feet perhaps
leader this question will arise in a
much more urgent manner and I should say
that it is inevitable democracy
bummers cup of tea as the professor put
it is modeled after the British
parliamentary system there are two
legislative houses of which the Chamber
of Deputies with 250 members is the most
important all but 54 members of the
house are members of the anti-fascist
people's freedom League dominated by the
patriot and philosopher uno for all but
one of Burma's nine years of
independence uno has been its prime
minister for the past eight months
who knew has been out of the prime
ministership and the cabinet so that he
could devote his time to ridding his
political party of corruption which has
at times frustrated its democratic
purposes the prime minister in his
absence is Oba sway who presides over a
cabinet whose average age is 40 and made
up of men who 15 years ago were school
teachers and resistance leaders in the
British Empire which ruled Burma almost
as a subsidiary of India Burma also has
a president Ubbe ooh who is really an
elected sovereign whose duties like
those of the former British
governor-general are mostly ceremonial
and diplomatic but in the spirit of
neutrality
the president has three automobiles Azis
presented by bull Gannon and Khrushchev
a Rolls Royce presented by Her Majesty's
Government and a Cadillac purchased from
General Motors the Burmese woman is
completely emancipated both politically
and socially keeps her maiden name and
property polygamy is legal but as
barrister Domeier thane told the
american women's club
rangoon you do understand that we have
we recognize polygamy and so a man is
entitled to have as many wives as he can
support I thank heaven we have this high
cost of living and there are not many
women really who aspire to being in the
harem since prehistoric times
we have always enjoyed an equality of
status rank and opportunity with men and
unlike the Chinese or the Indian
neighbors we have never been the chattel
of a Burmese man so nowadays you'll find
that we have 25% of Burmese women are in
the university and that all the leather
professions are open to women is it true
there at the present time marriages are
arranged here in Burma yes I think so
and they are quite successful especially
when the girls are young and the parents
feel that the children should be married
young was your marriage and arranged
marriage oh no my mother couldn't find
anybody for me you see I mean I was very
choosy I had to get one myself too
Burmese husbands help their wives with
the dishes heaven forbid we want to
uphold the dignity of the lord and
master of the house the rebirth of burma
is the story of a man and his religion
the religion is buddhism the man is uno
uno says Buddha means enlightened one
Buddhism is the cement that holds Burma
together this is the sweeter gun Kipling
called it the waking winking wonder
because this 326 foot pagoda built
before the birth of Christ is annually
in quested by thousands of pieces of
gold leaf plastered on as offerings by
but as unnal told reporter Nevin it is
not by this pyramid of guilt that the
new Burma will be built you know what
are those men doing high up on the
pagoda this needs a bit of explanation
as a matter of fact these concern with
the mundane affairs you see then with
these religious affairs because when a
man is sick or when a man is demoted or
when a man is that spent that you see
from his job he consults a
fortune-teller because he believes you
see that he is suffering from illness so
in order to counteract that ill luck he
offers goal lead to the Buddha which he
believes will bring some merit which can
counteract you see the ill luck which is
suffering from the person who pours
water on an image of the Buddha is doing
the same thing is doing the same thing
yes these are only superficial gestures
a very superficial very superficial the
the real thing that matters you see is
nothing but the meditation which can
deliver one you see from all suffering
she tell us a little about that although
I must tell you something from my own
experience I I was born a Buddhist so I
became a Buddhist and to tell you the
truth I was not a Buddhist in the true
sense of the term till very recently I
was very much attracted to Buddhism I
mean genuinely attracted to Buddhism
only after I have learned that the truth
of Buddhism can be tested Lord Buddha
said quite boldly you must not believe
anything which you cannot test yourself
and he also said that if person will
both rules for stages in this very life
not in the life year after and when a
person has gone through one of these
stages the mental transformation of that
person will be so complete that it will
give him enough conviction and faith to
make him a genuine Buddhist these words
very much attracted me towards Buddhism
so I tried it myself and not all of what
Buddha had said a portion because due to
lack of time as you know I cannot
possibly try oh but he had said and I
had tried some portion of it and I found
that to be true and since that time I
became a very much confirmed Buddhist
how long does it take to achieve that
state about a month of more or less
constant meditation yes and only method
must be constant yes meditation you
didn't do anything no no I want is not
supposed to do anything else
meditate in the monastery sir yes in the
monastery not necessarily in the
monastery you can do it at home so long
as it is a quiet home could you describe
the state which one reaches at the end
of this if the word serenity or
confidence or well it is it is quite
definite duty it is not a big thing
it is very clear for instance you see
you may be a Buddhist or you may be a
Christian or you may be a Muslim or you
may be anything music but if you ask
that man whether he believes his own
religion completely if he is a an honest
man he must tell you you see he must
admit that sometimes he is assailed by
doubts about his own religion the
religion he professes the Buddhist will
tell you the same thing but when he
reaches the first stage that doubt is
completely eliminated have you found
your Buddhist faith or help to you as
leader
of your party and this Prime Minister
who know very very much very very much
had it not been for my faith you see I
would have been finished you see in 1948
49 and 1550 when the insurrection was at
its height because everybody thought
that we were finished and we were not
finished because of that faith in his
time
who knew has translated Jefferson
Lincoln Karl Marx even Dale Carnegie for
his fellow burr me
he has also translated Buddhism for a
great many Americans the Lord Buddha
actually lived some 2,500 years ago he
was a prince born to greatness and glory
but when he realized that there was so
much suffering and misery in the world
he decided to become an ascetic of holy
men and seek out a way of life that
would free suffering humanity he made a
tremendous impression not only on his
own followers but also on all his
contemporaries and the story of his life
was handed down by word of mouth from
the generations to generations
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
when L was a boy of tally
he received his first formal
indoctrination in the concept of
Buddhism with the Xingu ceremony just as
this boy and every Burmese male have
been doing for centuries
uno explains that this is not to glorify
a god but an ideal the distinguishing
feature of Buddhism is to be found in
the practice of Buddhist doctrine this
involves the exercise of a rigid
personal discipline designed to attain a
serenity of mind which in turn will lead
to a way of escape from suffering and
distress in all countries there is the
desperate longing for peace but peace
like war begins in the minds of man many
people throughout the world are
beginning to realize this
and from one generation to the next
the Burmese boys at the age of about 10
spend a week or so as a novitiate monk
emulating the life of Lord Buddha there
is no commitment that he will make
monkhood his career like Lord Buddha who
gave up the luxury of a prince the
candidate is led in pomp and pageantry
to a ceremony where he gives up his
princely garments for the simple saffron
robe of the order his family watches as
his head is shaved a symbol of Buddhas
decision to forego the pleasures of the
world the boy will live with the older
monks in poverty and simplicity for at
least a week and if he chooses later on
for the rest of his life for this week
his only possessions will be his rolled
a needle a string of bead with which he
counts while meditating a razor to shave
his head with a strainer to strain
insects from his drinking water lest he
inflicts suffering on any living thing
and finally his begging bowl the monk
has no income he arises at dawn and goes
out barefoot along his route carrying a
lacquered begging bowl
from the devout he receives his daily
rice Buddhists do not call this an act
of begging it is the monks duty to
receive the housewives to offer if there
is any sense of privilege involved it is
on the part of the giver who has helped
to perpetuate the monkhood and therefore
the teachings of Lord Buddha the late
morning meal at the monastery is the
last of the day even for our young
friend the monk cannot take any
sustenance not even tea or coffee after
twelve known the rest of his day is
spent in studying and above all in
meditation which is the only real road
to Nirvana or ultimate purification oh
who said Buddhism is not a doctrine that
has to be accepted on hearsay it can be
tested by anyone and rejected or if at
the age of 20 the young Burmese wishes
to go on to ordination as a full-fledged
monk he can do so parts of the ceremony
are read from lacquered strips of bamboo
the language is poly comparable to Latin
in Catholicism he is asked are you a
free man have you come with the
permission of your parent have you any
diseases are your arms bowl and robe
complete
there are hundreds of thousands of
pagodas and shrines all over them and it
is almost impossible ever to be out of
sight of one Americans are somewhat too
inclined to think of Buddhism
principally in terms of the ornate
temples at Mandalay and began and mu
mein and the elaborate water procession
at inland lake with its unique and
world-famous black rose but as unnal
points out I think there is something
very romantic about you Americans
Buddhists do not worship any idols the
image of the Lord Buddha symbolizes his
teachings and his example for which
Buddhists have profound reverence in
much the same way I think that cross and
for Catholics the image of the Virgin
Mary and the images of various Saints
symbolizes of Christians the teachings
and example of Christ anyone can become
a Buddha if he practices the teachings
of the Lord Buddha with sufficient
diligence we have great reverence for
the Lord Buddha because he showed us the
way to mental serenity it is this
reverence that we show when we need
before his image or making offerings of
flowers upon incense in the pagodas
the relationship of the philosophy of
Buddhism to the doctrines of communism
will be discussed later by you know see
it now report on Burma Buddhism and
neutralism continues with reporter Paul
Niven on the Stillwell Road
this is boundary post 42 on the other
side of it the People's Republic of
China the beginning of the Communist
Empire the stretches a third of the way
around the globe in that village a
hundred yards away a squad of red
Chinese soldiers on this side the
Democratic Free Republic of Burma
independence since 1948 after a century
of British rule what was population 18
million compared with red China's 500
million this frontier stretches more
than a thousand miles already it's been
the subject of many disputes red Chinese
troops have crusted civilian settlers of
course did apparently having come to
Burma with the purpose this boundary
post itself was moved under cover of
dark one night by Chinese troops of
course the still road on which I'm
standing so that the road passed through
China the next night the Burmese moved
it back the real news look across this
road with a mixture of admiration and
dislike Burma admires communist China's
efficiency the national unity the
progress against disease and corruption
the billers disliked intensely the
regimentation of communism a denial of
the right to be a political they an
irreligious campaign which deeply
offends of religious people like the
Buddhists Berman's south of Burma line
Malaya Singapore Thailand and the new
countries carved out of Indochina
their future too depends on keeping
boundary post 42 in place so in the long
run made that of other nations a long
way off just down the road from boundary
post 42 at Nam Kham is an American who
we spent all of his life in Burma and on
this road ribbon dr. Gordan Seagrave
former Baptist missionary jungle surgeon
who walked out of Burma was still well
in 1941 humiliating defeat walked back
in 1945 to find his hospital in the
hills in total ruins his nurses too
representing all the races of Burma have
endured war and rebellion to win the
gratitude in respect of the Burmese
nation and hundreds of American GIs who
owe their lives to them several
generations of hill tribes the kitchens
the Sean's the Palin's delicious have
had their malaria and their tuberculosis
and their gonorrhea and their cancers
treated by daddy Seagrave and only him
his pay is $90 a month today and 59
suffering from dysentery and malaria
partially the result of imprisonment by
the Burmese for treason
he was later cleared see grave is both
old and a legend before his time doctor
see grave just hope for are you from the
Chinese border only a mile really it's
just an air mile over to the tongue of
China that comes into Burma here and the
lowest administrative point in communist
China is right across there and not
large abilities if you see across the
river and then the high mountains beyond
that are back in Burma again but makes a
rather difficult border situation for
Burma to take care of quite a number of
the people from China come over here we
report to the government the government
checks on their background and if
they're over here for real illness the
government gives us permission to go
ahead and treat them because that's part
of the government policies to is to
treat them properly this is a rather
explosive border situation you're living
in is it own we are actually
right on the vid of course my first
responsibility is to the government a
bummer I must not be the cause of
trouble between Burma and China and then
my gratitude to Burma is so great that
if an explosion ever occurred that they
led ever blew off what I would do then
would be to offer my services to the
army of Burma and take care of their
cousins just as long as I'm alive that's
the only way that I can discharge my
responsibilities to a country that's
been as friendly to me as this country
had doctor I think many Americans would
be interested in hearing your story of
how you were arrested and imprisoned in
1950-51
my trouble was that we had been serving
Burma for so many many years well over a
hundred years that I thought I was above
suspicion then another thing that that
got me into trouble was the fact that I
was born among the currents and the
first language that I ever learned was
correct and they believed of course of
my system my heart was where the
currents you see you were arrested here
yes
actually finishing my morning coffee
when they came to the house and I was
taking down the Rhine ruin and when I
was given the chance to get out of the
country without a trial
why didn't you I didn't want to leave
here as a traitor I didn't want the
people in Burma to believe that I was a
traitor I didn't want the people in
America to believe that I was guilty of
treason against this country Americans
loved the people of Burma the Americans
have fought here in Burma love the
people of Burma and if I had gone back
to America without a trial I would have
merely convicted myself of treason and I
didn't believe I was guilty of treason
now I didn't know I should behave what
the state of justice was in Burma I'll
admit and there at the beginning I felt
that I was being abused but one of my
fellow prisoners and the deal said I
didn't mean to worry about the justice
of Burma that was one thing that Burma
had a right to be proud of and he was
right was your lawyer and American dr.
Seagram my lawyer was anything but an
American my lawyer was a Burmese one of
the finest men in Burma some of my old
friends of the china burma india theater
wrote me a letter from denver saying
that they would send one of these
high-powered American lawyers out here
to defend me and I didn't want that
because I I wanted to trust the justice
of the people of Burma I think that
would have been the worst mistake I ever
made if I'd brought an American lawyer
out here the palm on the table and do
that sort of thing it is much better
being scared by Burmese doctor how is
America doing in this part of the world
I think America is doing a whole lot
better than America
realized there was a bit of a strain
back that the time of the that the
nationalist Chinese aggression was
taking place in Burma because four
months after it began America didn't
seem to pay any attention to it and they
were tearing this country apart and just
because they used the word nationalist
Americans seem to think that that
aggression didn't amount to much that it
was justified in some way or other and
some Americans claim that these were the
only Chinese that were really fighting
the Communists and therefore Burma ought
to be more tolerant well I didn't feel
that way at all because the Chinese
nationalists had been around here and
had been shooting things up right and
left they weren't here to base
themselves it for drive against China at
all they were here just for their own
personal aggrandizement but then as soon
as President Eisenhower got well settled
into the presidency he began to get
reports from the Ambassador in Rangoon
and American reaction changed in America
helped get rid of those people and I
think American prestige went up
immensely the business of Burma is white
and unlike other underdeveloped
countries of the world no matter what
happens
Burma eats it raises eight million
bushels of rice a year more than it can
eat itself and more than it seems able
to export this is a farm a booming ji
who like eighty five percent of the
population is a rice farmer as the
professor at Rangoon University said
earlier before independence most of
Burma's rice fields were owned by
absentee landlords and until 1947 Umang
ji was a tenant farmer barely managing
to eke out a living
then came nationalization of the land
and he was given twenty acres to run as
his own and thirty more that the
government holds but lets him run land
is assigned according to the size of a
man's family but 50 acres is the maximum
permitted there is little mechanization
of Agriculture in Burma
whoo monkey has no tractor no threat the
threshing is done by the hands of mangy
his wife who smoke sure oops and his 10
children in the socialist type economy
of Burma hulling is done by the state
Marketing Board mill which fixes price
and export see after expenses Uman gee
that's about three hundred and twenty
dollars a year which is considered good
he says if he had more capital he would
start a small cigar making business
farmer ji knows only vaguely that
Burma's major problem is her one crop
economy and recent efforts to sell some
of the surplus to the United States
misfired because we ended up selling at
the Pakistan ordinarily a big customer
of Burma he also knows something about
the recent barter deal in which Burma
swapped its rice with Russia for cement
and heavy equipment but this ended in
better disillusionment for the Burmese
who were shortchanged in an effort to
free itself of the hardships of the one
crop economy which means that Burma has
to buy almost everything she needs in
foreign markets the Burmese government
has gone into several diversified
industries this modern plant in Rangoon
makes vaccines antibiotics and other
vital pharmaceuticals the plant built by
a British contractor is being run by a
British pharmaceutical firm on a
contract basis and will be turned over
to the Burmese in 1960 when they hope to
be able to run it by themselves there
are those critics in and out of the
country who claim the Burmese lacked
know-how and are an indolent and lazy
people and that present-day Rangoon is a
squalid monument to this it is true that
the literacy rate is low and the Burmese
government has launched an adult
education plan to counteract this it is
our job to rebuild Burma material as
well as moral mass education aimed at
wiping out disease poverty and ignorance
Hmong people
and at the same time making them realize
there are new responsibilities as
citizens of an independent southern
states and this is the opportunity the
challenge math education offers you
because it is you who must walk this
program on you will go into the field
depends the taxes of this program the
mass education plan has already sent
more than a thousand teachers into the
field to teach well digging latrine
building malaria control home
construction and just plain reading Toby
on the lake we don't look so down upon
what the market I loved your novel on
October 1 or the Loch canard à la I
cover the one our the love
as in Africa and other parts of Asia the
most exciting thing to be seen in Burma
is a group of adults learning to write
their own name God da da da da Wow
let me look ba da ba da da black God
yeah no not yeah yeah no not the United
Nations has several teams working in
Burma as does the Ford Foundation but
there is no point for or any other
official US government aid uno stopped
it in 1953 in token of his non-alignment
policy Burma now desires US aid but
insist on paying it back and
unfortunately there is no category for
this
Lewis will insky an American economist
employed by the Burmese talks about this
Burma is making rather steady progress
toward overcoming her problems given
time I think she can solve them by
herself but with Communist China on her
border she feels she doesn't have very
much time the United States has helped
Burma wants to help her now Burma wants
to pay for the help she gets to me it's
ironic that it is easier for us to
extend aid on a gift basis or on a grant
PLUS loans basis than on a loans
repayable basis we've imposed so many
restrictions to ensure that nations
which receive our gifts use them in ways
we approve this isn't altogether
appropriate for a country which will
repay 100 percent the help she gets
equally important we just can't we just
can't seem to move fast enough in these
matters
for these reasons our aid to Burma thus
far has been too little too late and too
complicated if not for this I think
Burma today and our position in this
part of the
world would be stronger than it is if we
Americans want to help struggling
democracies like Burma to achieve their
objectives and to build with us a free
and better world we should shake off
these self-imposed restrictions that
hamper our efforts and frustrate our
national purpose another symbol of
Burma's freedom is the freedom of the
press and nowhere in Asia is it
practiced with more vigor than by IDI
low yawn editor of the nation it was low
yawn rather than the government who
announced to Burma and the world that
Chinese Communist troop had violated
Burma's northern border like Jefferson
he trusts newspapers more than the
government like Jefferson he opposes
single-party rule it will be realized
that although we have a parliamentary
form of government Parliament's is not
in fact well-established in this country
there is a preponderance of a one-party
rule which to me is in the long run as
dangerous as having autocracy much as it
as I respect and admire the leaders of
the present government I hole entirely
with the view that power corrupts and
that absolute power corrupts absolutely
now we have been critical as I said
about the government both on domestic
and foreign policy I have said
repeatedly that I do not believe
neutralism to be a safe policy perhaps
at the present juncture in history there
is no substitute for neutralism perhaps
it will have to endure for some little
time but while we sit on the fence being
friendly with both blocks I think and
I'm sure our government is realizing it
do that in our own interests in the
interests of our safety we should try to
make the democracies morally and
physically strong there is a spectacle
in Burma of too much money chasing too
few goods in desperation therefore we
had to enter into party deals with a
communist bloc these body deals have not
done as much good but if they were
entered into in the first instance
because it's a kind of vicious circle we
had to get rid of our rice and we had to
go in for imports of capital goods a
heavy machinery we knew from the very
beginning that we were not going to get
the canned goods at the prices that we
were used to pay but it was better than
not getting anything at all but looking
back now I think that the whole thing is
being a blessing in disguise we have
found out in the hard school experience
that good that we have been used to
buying from the West are cheaper and
definitely superior to the goods that we
can procure from the communist bloc
regardless of what the future may hold
regardless of the outcome of the
negotiations which our government is
entering into it Communist China over
the whole border question I believe that
my countrymen now fully aroused realize
that it is it would be foolish to put
implicit faith in the communist leaders
every capital in Southeast Asia has its
Chinatown and often the biggest and most
powerful bank in town is a Communist
Chinese pang controlled from Beijing
which uses it as an instrument of
subversion to get a loan from this Bank
a Burmese Chinese has to promise to
educate his children at a communist
school the Chinese community and Burma
is still divided but every national
holiday seize them displaying fewer
junga shek flags and more hammer and
sickles
who knew has banned the Communist Party
in Burma but in the interest of freedom
permits the widest latitude in political
demonstrations particularly among the
students many of whom are communists in
everything except name while we were
there a Rangoon University election
returned the communist dominated student
government by a majority of two to one
but even those in the university who
opposed the Communists also oppose any
alignment with the west and contend that
neutrality is strictly a matter of
geography American people would like to
know why Burma is neutral and as a
student I would like to explain why we
are government take this step as you
know our close friend like India this
people to India and Burma are neutral
countries Burmese neutral why because
you can look at the geography of
situation we have our country is
situated right close to where China
that's a communist nation
I don't think Red China would invade it
because I believe in the terms making
between X Prime Minister who knew and
Prime Minister of Red China
watch online that's why we we can trade
with China that we can trade with West
and also America if we side with America
if we side with the American block do we
have freedom to have a friendly
relations with each other with a with
the Chinese and the Russians and also
have trade with them I don't think it'd
be possible we end our report on Bhama
why it began with uno at the shredder
gun do you think there is in the West
anyth basis for a moral appeal or a
moral fervor that can hold its own
against the material appeal of communism
I do not want you to underestimate the
moral appeal as against the material
appeal of any ISM you see in the world
because I'm quite confident that it will
be the moral appeal that will ultimately
triumph this communism have a moral
appeal or and it so is the genuine one I
do not think you see the the the
communism has any moral appeal because I
want to tell you some of the I mean
experiences of my own in from 1948 to
1950 for three years more than 9/10 of
the country had been in the hands of the
insurgents
there's the slogans of lends to the
tillers factories to the workers and so
on caught the imagination of the of the
people more easily than anything else we
could possibly say to that to these
people at that time and so most of the
people supported the insurgents and a
bit time we had no arms and what was was
was we had no soldiers to fight the
insurgents but we kept on saying to the
people
this yes you may get lens as you may get
factories and you may even get all the
things you want from the government's
toes under the incidence but mind you
you will lose the fundamental freedoms
which you must possess as a human being
the people were in that lesson do you
think after some time they realized that
what we told them was by true and since
that time quite a lot of people who had
given support shelter and food you see
to the incidents turned away from these
people and in certain cases these people
fought them put whatever arms they
possessed and now you see more than 9/10
of the country is in our hands and I
must tell you that our triumph over the
incident is the triumph of the moral
appeal of other material appeal you've
often said that one of the worst things
about the Burmese communists is that
they take orders from their foreign
masters presumably those foreign masters
are in China and Russia and yet when you
go to Moscow or vaping everything is
very friendly
we in the West don't quite understand
this sir are we friendly only with the
Communists are we not friendly with also
with the NT communists thank Bible why
why is it you see that this friendship
you see with the Communists should
puzzled you in the West why well I think
it puzzles us we are friendly with with
everybody but not was the greater
Communist Party which is outward yes it
was outlawed because they were not
communists they were outlawed because
they they try to overthrow the
government by violent means if they like
to contest in the I mean elections and
seized power through Democratic means
they will be given I mean full freedom
to come and contest in elections
thank you one of the characters in your
play the people went through says that
communism in China and communism in
Burma and not at all the same thing
could you explain that yes communism in
China means the raising of the standard
of living of the people whereas
communism in Burma means taking orders
from outside as you told me just now you
feel the accomplishments of the Chinese
communist government match up or away
the loss of freedom that is taking place
there I was not long enough in China you
need to find out all these but I must
tell you that I give a good deal of
credit duty to what the Chinese leaders
are doing for their own people they are
very much devoted to the welfare of the
Chinese people do you think the United
States should recognize communist China
and that she should be admitted to the
United Nations yes you may not believe
in communism you see I for instance I
don't believe in communism myself but we
recognized I recognized China everyone
with whom we talked here in Rangoon
indicates that Brimmer wants socialism
permanently as a way of life now that
you visited the United States who know
do you still feel that american-style
capitalism is not relevant to Burma's
problems the conditions in the United
States and in the countries in Asia are
quite different
so if we introduce american-style
capitalism into the countries in Asia I
think it will bring about undesirable
economic discrepancies the rich will
become richer very much richer and the
old the poor become will become very
much poorer so in that case it will
bring about much discontent and
dissatisfaction you see throughout Asia
then I believe it will be issuer means
of of installing communists in Southeast
Asia so I do not want american-style
capitalism to be introduced into
Southeast Asia sir I see it now
interview with you three years ago
sander Margaret chase Smith asked you if
you had any criticisms to make of
American policy you were very polite as
I remember but you said you thought
American politicians talk too much do
you still feel that way yes but I don't
find fault seriously with with the
Americans for talking too much in
America you know very well you see there
is freedom of speech so they enjoy it to
the fullest extent that is the reason
yes when you look at this great nation
of ours from the outside even from Burma
you realize that in terms of freedom our
example may be quite as important as our
dollars the night and good luck